I have the more of the white particles in view below the capsule.
They appear to be traveling exactly. My speed there is one drifting off.
It's going faster than I am, I'm super hurtful.
I understand.
I haven't seen the great numbers of these particles, but I've seen the few of them.
Their motion is a random. They look exactly like snowflakes to me.
I'd rather have you tried our return to negative, let me get within scanner limits first.
I must adjust my attitude to within scanner limits first.
Roger.
There were some more of those little particles they definitely look like snowflakes this time.
Roger, I understand your opponent looks like this and it smells like snowflakes.
However, it's time. Roger.